good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video about shooting stars
and seeing streaks of light at nighttime
reminded me that it is Firefly season
here in Indiana and today I'd like to
tell you about my complicated
relationship with fireflies or as I
called them as a child lightning bugs so
I always thought of fireflies as a
singular thing but in fact around the
world there are over 2,000 species of
these soft-bodied luminescent beetles
some glow with amber light some with
green some with yellow they can tell
each other apart by the pattern and
color of their flashes some species even
glow in sync with one another so that
entire trees full of fireflies look like
Christmas trees with lights blinking on
and off some fireflies are predators in
fact members of the Firefly family
futurus will mimic the light patterns of
other species of fireflies so as to
attract and eat them here in
Indianapolis there are dozens of species
of fireflies one the sayz firefly became
the state insect of Indiana in 2018
Indiana's Department of Natural
Resources released a statement pointing
out that the says-- firefly is a true
Indiana native whereas and I'm quoting
here many other states have state
insects that are not native to their
areas a dis presumably intended for our
neighboring state of Ohio which chose as
their state insect the seven spotted
ladybug an invasive species introduced
to the United States in 1973 but I'm not
here to talk about Ohio's dubious
selection of state symbols I'm here to
talk about fireflies which are of course
absurdly wonderful the problem with
fireflies though is that they are so
obviously and ostentatiously beautiful
that they can be like a little cheesy I
remember once in high school I was
outside with a friend and she commented
on how the fireflies were really lovely
and I said well but they're a little
lame though and she paused for a moment
before saying what is wrong with you
what was wrong with me was that I was
afraid to experienced an IRA NIH's
demotion afraid that if I gave in to the
phenomenal beauty of fireflies I would
seem childish or naive or worst of all
that I would be seen as innocent
and vulnerable and I was right to worry
about that I knew by then that it is not
only carnivorous fireflies that were in
the innocent and vulnerable only to hurt
them so when I was a kid fireflies were
an example to me of the world's
strangeness and beauty of the absolute
astonishment that life exists at all let
alone in such bizarre abundance and then
in my teens and 20s fireflies
represented to me a beauty I needed to
protect myself against feeling too much
or too directly lest I drown in either
misguided nostalgia or the flood of
emotion I was always trying to dam up
within myself but now they mean
something else to me what gets me about
fireflies these days is that they make
their own light I mean they get their
energy from the Sun just like the rest
of us do and so in a way their light is
sunlight just like all earth light is
but still fireflies make light where
otherwise there wouldn't be any Hank you
told me recently that there are planets
in the universe that orbit no star
planets that are just hurtling through
the vast and empty places between solar
systems and on those planets you
explained everything is very dark all
the time and when I asked you if there
might be life on those planets you
explained that yeah perhaps if there are
geological temperature differentials or
something there might be energy that
could be captured and used to fuel some
kind of life and then you said but there
wouldn't be any light though before
pausing and adding oh unless they make
it themselves and I found that
possibility however distant quite
encouraging so here's to celebrating
light where we find it and making light
where we don't Hank I'll see you on
Friday